how is parenthood how is it how do you
like the experience it's good it's good
I'm loving it my son is your winch twins
yeah yeah they're seven and my son is
doing this thing now where I walk in the
house and he goes Wanda Sykes
work those Wanda Sykes yeah like why is
he doing that um I think he's definitely
trying to annoy me but it's it's it's
because like when we're out and in the
street or something you know shopping or
whatever people walk by you know you get
Coco yeah yes so people won't they see
me they go hey Wanda Sykes or like hey
Wanda hey Wanda sighs you know I think
it's starting to annoy the kids it's
bothering them so now when I walk in the
house it's like oh why the psychs it's
so you know it's weird - it's a little
bit like it's sarcastic but it's also I
think when kids don't call you you know
mom or for me I'm there was a period
where my son he could tell that it got
to me he would always call was always
dad or daddy and then one day it was
like hey gone and oh like no no I'm not
Conan I'm dad you know that's what I
call me right and but he won he sued me
are your kids I'm curious how your kids
know your work that well do they say
have they seen your show have you seen
Pootie Tang oh god no that by the way
Pootie Tang I have gone on record and
said the greatest I have studied all the
films made in the history of America and
Europe Pootie Tang best title of any
movie ever no no god I hope my kids
never see that movie because because
they'll never listen to me again like
yeah I mean I can't say anything to them
it's gonna be hard to discipline my
daughter if you know she walks out of
the house at a little midriff and a
short shorts or something I'm like hey
you're not leaving the house dressed
like that and she'll turn and go
excuse me biggie shorty I was pretty
much half naked in the film so that that
was suck yeah my sign came up to me
recently and he said he said what's
pornography and I was like what do you
mean or do you hear that word and he
went on a Simpsons episode you wrote
that seal didn't feel good now didn't
feel good he does not allowed to watch
TV anymore
you